it's a monday pft pm from the bar and
we've got jaguars general manager dave
caldwell coming up momentarily before we
get to that though i need to say a few
things about the late dawn shula hall of
famer one of the great coaches of all
time and he was the man back when i
discovered football in the 70s and you
know when you're a little kid and
for all you know the dolphins are a
powerhouse the idea that the dolphins
just kind of popped onto the scene in
the late 60s and became that good of a
team
that quickly that's unheard of back then
those were the years of the five-year
plan the time that it took to develop
and grow through the draft you didn't
have free agency you didn't have other
ways to make your team better quickly
and for donald schuler to take a team
that was an expansion team and to turn
it that fast into a super bowl team a
team that went to three straight super
bowls lost super bowl six to the cowboys
one super bowl seven after going 17-0
still the only perfect season with a
super bowl win on the end of it and then
winning another super bowl super bowl
eight
and continuing to be
a great coach even though they didn't
win another super bowl under don chula
he would coach the team through 1995. he
retired with a winning percentage above
two out of three so on average he won
more than two out of three games that he
coached in the regular season it really
was an incredible run when you think
back to the 70s and and again for me
it's still vivid because those were the
years that i
discovered it that i found it that i
realized and i looked up to these guys
like dawn sure like chuck noll tom
landry bud grant john madden
and there are other great coaches from
that era chuck knox bum phillips i mean
there were so many great coaches in the
70s george allen who was the coach of
the washington team that the dolphins
beat it really was a special time
in professional football and
the league was dominated by
the dolphins then the steelers then the
cowboys then the raiders got their super
bowl win and there was a small handful
of teams that really ran the show
and don shula in many ways was the
godfather because he had that 17-0
season and to do what he did as quickly
as he did it with a team that was
starting from absolute scratch now
steelers fans would say that their
franchise was so bad when chuck noll got
there in 1969 it was basically the same
thing but schulich still did it faster
right the year of the immaculate
reception the steelers lost that next
week to the dolphins who were on their
way to that 17-0 season so
it was a great great run for don schula
as the dolphins head coach and it was
very very saddening to see that he had
passed today at the age of nine but also
brings back some great memories of
football back in the 70s a different
time a different place and an era where
the coaches were
even more larger than life than they are
today and they are today to a certain
extent but maybe it's because i was a
kid then and and now i kind of know
these guys and there's less of uh
of this awe but boy back in the 70s
there was something about just the names
shula knoll grant landry madden there
was just something about that that
inspired both awe and uh and passion for
football so with that said we're going
to move on to jaguars general manager
dave caldwell and then we'll see you
back later this week for some more pft
pm up next our interview with jaguar gm
dave caldwell
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports